le rapport qui aurait pu éclabousser le
gouvernement Trudeau le commissaire
rouleau lui donne finalement raison le
recours à la Loi sur les mesures
d'urgence était appropriée pour mettre
fin ou convoi des camionnettes le
cabinet avait des motifs raisonnable de
croire qu'il existait une crise
nationale en raison de menaces pour la
sécurité du Canada
Ottawa était confronté à une crise qui
dégénérait et risquait de devenir
ingérable conclut le commissaire juste
un Trudeau peut pousser un soupir de
soulagement on est tous d'accord qu'on
n'aurait jamais dû en arriver là et on
est tous d'accord qui a des leçons
importantes à tirer mais le juge rouleau
conserve un goût amer c'est donc à
contrecoeur que je parviens à cette
conclusion selon lui cette crise aurait
pu être évitée la réponse au convoi de
la liberté comprenait une série d'échecs
en matière de maintien de l'ordre
écrit-il il montre du doigt le service
de police d'Ottawa qui a mal évalué la
durée se manifestations dans la capitale
autre constat sévère les événements de
janvier et février 2022 peuvent être
aussi considérées comme un échec du
fédéralisme écrit le commissaire il
déplore le manque du coordination entre
les différents ordres de gouvernement
pour faire face à la crise et reproche
notamment au Premier ministre ontarien
dogford sont manque de collaboration tu
as juste un Trudeau que l'opposition
veut faire porter le blâme le chef
conservateur l'accuse d'avoir attisé la
colère des manifestants en faisant cette
division juste un trou d'eau à cause des
urgence qu'on a vu à atawa et à 56
recommandations le juge recommande des
réformes majeures pour améliorer le
partage de renseignements et de
ressources entre les forces policières
Paul rouleau recommande aussi de
moderniser la loi et la définition de
l'état d'urgence sur le plan personnel
juste un Trudeau assure avoir tiré des
leçons de ces événements ils sont vus
d'avoir mis de l'huile sur le feu en
qualifiant les manifestants de marginaux
oui je regrette pas avoir choisi mes
mots avec un peu plus de délicatesse les
corps policiers
chez de la commission rouleau et Justin
Trudeau semble s'en tirer à bon compte
mais le gouvernement fédéral sera jugé
sur le sérieux de sa réponse aux
réformes proposées par le commissaire
afin d'éviter qu'une telle débâcle ne se
reproduise ici Louis Blouin Radio-Canada
Ottawa